Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. The number
is 2192. David P, I made a mistake last week
and I apologize for it. I'll remind you
what the mistake was. And it relates
to Charlie and the Chocolate Factory.
Speaker 2: Violet Beauregard turns into
a blueberry. Not a gun. Just glue. The glue. He is
so fat that he gets stuck in the whatever tubing
system is carrying the chocolate out of her.
But it was Violet Beauregard equal to the blue,
to the size of a blueberry and turned blue.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So last week we were talking
on the bonus show. You know,
the bonus show, I hope. Oh, the.
Speaker 3: Bonus show Where you want
to make money? Yes. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We were talking about the effort to
rewrite elements of Roald Dahl's books, including
Willy Wonka, The Willy Wonka's Chocolate Factory,
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory. Well, I forget
the book. The book and movie have a different
name. In any case, one of the things is they don't
like Augustus Gloop being described as enormously
fat anymore. That's, I guess, wrong. So publishers
want to change it to something else. And I was
describing, you know, he's like, he smells like a
blueberry. But that is not the story. It is indeed
violet that swirls like a blueberry. And Augustus
Gloop is the one who gets, like, stuck in the
piping, I guess, of the chocolate factory. I was
wrong about what I said. My analysis is the same,
which I am against the rewriting of books. I think
the book is a complete act. It is not to be now
retrospectively modified. Yes. Roald Dahl was
a horrible anti-Semite. That's a separate issue
from whether we should mess with the vocabulary
in the book. And we had an extensive conversation
about this with Pat on the bonus show, which
I welcome you to check out. But I was wrong
in my retelling of the story and I apologize. We
have a great bonus show for you today. Democrats
have seen a major shift and now prefer Joe Biden
as the nominee. Interesting. An Idaho bill would
criminalize giving money vaccines. What? Why?
You can probably guess. And the Pentagon is
warning that poppy seed bagels could be a threat
to national security. Yes, it is related to the
Seinfeld episode about the poppy seed bagels. So
we will talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Please do yourselves a
favor. Sign up at join Packman dot com before
they take your machine. We're doing.
Speaker 3: A class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: Before they
take your phone and your espresso
machine and your desktop computer
and all of that. Get a membership at
Join Patch. I'll see you on the bar.